you know what
I just feel numb I feel angry him some
ways because I wasn't there when he died
they told the life-support machine off
four layers Rhodes family the raw
emotion is understandable regret
they weren't contacted in time to be
with him in his final hours coupled with
a visceral hatred for the attacker who
ended the pensioners life I think you
should have suffered the way that all
the families now suffering through this
one man decided to do damage scan one
person's unbelievable him one person to
do all that damage sick individual man
less roads have been returning from a
hospital appointment when he was caught
up in the Westminster attack struck by
Khalid Masood scar on Westminster Bridge
he's destroyed how many families they've
got children you know for what for a
careless attacking in a car decides to
Gartland down westminster bridge gets a
knife at kills a policeman and then
moulds down well there's no other words
I saw I can say sorry I've got no
remorse for him whatsoever
the 75 year olds family hadn't had as
much contact with him in recent years
but his niece still remembers the sweet
man who acted like a father when her own
dad died I still love waiting for this
to come up because to me Liz looks so
much like my dad and it was like my dad
walking along and I've got comfort for
that you know this was lovely come up
with Christmas presents then he was just
a natural presence the families of all
those who died and many of the injured
will attend a special service at
Westminster Abbey on Wednesday the Duke
and Duchess of Cambridge among those who
be there to offer their support and
comfort on her really hurt for one
individual that decided to get in a car
and mow people down discussed him no
time